because i think a lot of people by
nature i think they want to be better i
think they just don't always know how or
have the examples or have the awareness
so what do you do what can you do to
sort of cultivate that awareness and
cultivate that ability to be able to see
the things that are going on in your
life that are holding you back and fall
into a loop or a pattern
well
i have a practical answer for that if if
you want to get better
i developed a writing set of writing
exercises with my colleagues
right so there's well we have two
exercises one's a personality test and
so
for self-awareness that can be really
useful
in fact if you take it with your partner
you get a couple's report
so it'll tell you
10
10 aspects of your personality clumped
into five factors extroversion so how
social you are and how positive how
bubbly how enthusiastic how assertive
how talkative that's all extraversion
neuroticism that's negative emotion
almost all of them
anger irritability fear guilt shame
despair disgust
disgust is a little unique but all the
negative emotions clump together and
people differ in their susceptibility to
that
agreeableness
women are more agreeable than men by
quite a substantial margin it's
associated with compassion and
politeness
and so disagreeable people they're more
blunt
they'll tell you they're less conflict
avoidant yes no doubt no doubt no doubt
yeah it'd be interesting to take the
personality test and see where you fall
because my suspicions are that for a
woman you're quite disagreeable and
that's not a that's not a uh insult by
the way agreeableness is quite a weird
dimension because there are marked
positive and negative attributes all
along the entire dimension
so disagreeable people if they're really
disagreeable they can be callous and
unkind and cruel and antisocial
um but very very agreeable people can be
dependent and
and over nurturing and devouring you
know on the on the
i'll never let you go end of the
spectrum
right so that's agreeableness
conscientiousness that's orderliness and
industriousness it's the best predictor
of lifetime success apart from general
cognitive ability which is iq
essentially and openness which is
creativity
and it's associated with um
well interest in diverse activities and
novelty aesthetic experiences
and interest and ideas philosophical
ideas and so
um you do a podcast you're probably
pretty high in openness oh
yeah i am very high in openness is this
the future what's it called this is
called understand myself
and if you do it you get a report for
you and if your partner does it you get
a report for them and both of you and
the
reason we did that that's a relatively
new innovation by the way um the reason
we did that is because
it's not easy for people to understand
each other and they often feel that
their partner is being arbitrary so for
example my parents my mother is very
extroverted and my father is quite
introverted especially he's low in
enthusiasm and so my mom would just as
soon be out with people having fun all
the time but that exhausts my dad
and introverts get exhausted by social
interactions i think they're more
they're more their niche is one-on-one
and maybe being in nature
whereas extroverts they want to be in
society
and they tell jokes and they smile and
they blink more and there's all sorts of
things that go along with it
but if you're extroverted and your
partner's introverted you've got a
problem because you're always going to
be wanna gonna be out and about and that
energizes you and when you're not with
people that is you're gonna be unhappy
or you're gonna be not happy not unhappy
because that's neuroticism but you're
not gonna be happy the positive emotion
is gonna go away and so how do you
bridge that gap that's how you are it's
not some arbitrary decision it's built
into you and so if you really diverge in
extraversion well that's a problem
if you're both really high in negative
emotion
you're going to be setting yourself off
you're the two of you off all the time
right so and as i said that higher
levels of neuroticism are associated
with marital unhappiness so if you're
both high in neuroticism that might be
the one dimension where you don't want
to be like your partner if you're if
it's high
right for someone who's high in
neuroticism they might really like to
have a stable uh a stable partner who's
who's less
threat sensitive
so
and then agreeableness well agreeable
people they're easy to get along with
their conflict avoidant but they can be
pushovers and so if your partner is
disagreeable and you're agreeable it's
going to be hard for you to stand your
ground because you're going to get run
over
so awareness is comes through actually
wanting it well there's well there's
that but also also understanding to some
degree understanding what the
differences are like i thought my
daughter was more disagreeable than she
is when she took my test she took the
test and it showed that she was higher
negative emotion than i thought and so
what i saw as
combative
was reactive anxiety
and that was really helpful to me
because i thought it was combative it
wasn't
so
and
i thought i'd be able to tell that but i
couldn't
so people high negative emotion can be
irritable and so that looks like
combativeness but it's defensive
disagreeable people can be more
predatory they're out to get what they
want they want to win you know and
that's different